there is evidence
it has a certain amount of noise in it
your expertise
involves uh compiling evidence of
different kinds
uh discovering the signal within it
dealing with noisy data sets and
reaching a conclusion about patient
well-being and potentially
epidemiological effect of a given
treatment
what you are seeing with respect to the
body of evidence that applies to
and its utility both as a treatment and
a prophylactic
uh for covid how
is that resulting in a
is that informing policy with respect to
the use
of in a way that is familiar to you
or is there something unusual going on
here no it's really very unusual
um i've never seen such a huge body of
evidence being ignored
many of the recommendations that are
made
on um you know the guideline panels that
i've
been involved with are based on far less
evidence recommendations and favor
sometimes it's possible for there to be
no clear
evidence of effect even but because an
intervention is highly
acceptable desirable and feasible
a decision might be made uh in favor of
it
so um so it's very unusual for such a
huge body of evidence to be ignored and
to be calling for more
large trials to support us like this
video
subscribe to the channel and consider
writing a comment and because 1984 has
captured 2021 click the link in the
description to see the full clip
on odyssey
you